ladies and gentlemen Owen Wilson who was
nominated for an Oscar tonight and Ben
Stiller who is not
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
writers bring the words directors bring
the vision but it's the costume designer
who transforms actors into characters
take a look at this the costume designer
is the unsung hero of the movie business
with the right diaper like toga they can
turn a sexy beast into Gandhi or the
similar diaper like toga turn a math nut
into a fierce gladiator or even take a
carefully selected pair of glasses and
turn a tenon bomb into magical Harry
Potter but with the right frock turn a
[ __ ] into a lord of the ring man
that's your cue come on I don't think I
want to do this on here come on let me
see into a water balloon it works it
works go ahead do your bit ever since
primitive man first amused his fellow
tribes members by wearing animal skins
and headdresses man has entertained
himself through the use of cos for me
I want to cue up the spooky caveman
music when he does that this is just
humiliating this isn't humiliating come
on a billion people are gonna watch this
get your head in the game exactly a
billion people and look at me look at me
I look like a freakin ZZ Top troll boy
that's going here come on put the
headgear back on get your head in the
game come on you want to piss off the
Academy Oh oh no no I wouldn't want to
piss off the Academy company man
wouldn't want to piss them off what is
this about I thought you said you
weren't jealous of Wes and I getting
nominated you were happy for us I am
happy for you I think it's great in fact
I think you should have gotten another
nomination for that behind enemy lines
movie for best running cuz that was
incredible
you know what this is why you don't get
the good scripts cuz you're difficult
and I'm saying that as a friend good
scripts I can Shanghai noon to what do
they call that one Shanghai 12:30 oh I'm
sorry you didn't get nominated for Zhu
Li and whatever and that was a real
shock oh I don't think the town hasn't
been that surprised since uh Scorsese
got over the ratings go on come on not
worth it writer director actor quitter
sorry we both got a little heated I'm
sorry about calling you quitter
sorry sorry but you did look good as an
owl thank you thank you for Middleburg
and the nominees for best achievement
and costume design are milena can an
arrow for the affair of the necklace
[Music]
[Applause]
Jenny Beavan for Gosford Park
[Applause]
[Music]
Judy Anna makovski for Harry Potter and
the Sorcerer's Stone
[Applause]
Nayla Dixon and Richard Taylor for the
Lord of the Rings the Fellowship of the
Ring Katherine Martin an Angus trophy
for Iran Ruth
[Music]
and the Oscar goes to Catherine Martin
and Angus stroppy from Moulin Rouge
[Applause]
these are the first officers for
Katherine Martin and Angus Rafi
[Applause]
300 costumes and at one point 80 people
were employed
[Music]
I'm fumbling we would like to thank the
Academy this award represents thousands
of man-hours of delicate but nonetheless
back-breaking work of over a hundred of
our colleagues and countrymen we thank
them all thanks to Angus who's beside me
now and was beside me when we did
everything and to the extraordinary Baz
Luhrmann who has got us up here who
cares as much about the embroidery
detail on a can-can skirt as he does
about lens size or dialogue it was your
vision this is your Oscar verse we would
also like to thank the best for wardrobe
supervisor I think anybody could hope
for in Eliezer Godman the beautiful
pictures of Don McAlpine thank you to
the mob lism hair and makeup about Omer
Ezio and Leslie and their teams
nevertheless we'd like to also thank the
continual lovin support of our family
friends and loved ones for me the
rewards of this film haven't well before
tonight I'll be eternally grateful
for the joy given by this girl and our
Baz Luhrmann thank you
[Applause]